- I wanted to map my
experience as an improviser
becoming Trump to the movie
Tootsie and just do a tootsie
and have me teaching
improve, open the same way
as Tootsie. You gotta
work and you gotta do this
and then I can't job and
the I wear the orange wig
which is just like tootsie,
she's got read hair
and then just do the beats of it
and then reveal myself like
the republican convention.
- Oh man that still could happen
- I think it would be a
great special idea now
we've put it out on a comedy
central
affiliated radio program
- Yes, there all listening,
or at least pretending to
- Now it has to happen, exactly
(rock music)
- I had something happen
to me this weekend
that I just want to
celebrate before we get
into anything else, is
that I left my purse
in a cab yesterday.
It was devastating.
But I mean, I always say
because I practice meditation,
I didn't freak out. I really
think that's the reason
that I don't, because
generally I would just go
Oh my god, you're such
fucking idiot, yell at myself
and my passport was in there,
and that's my only for of
identification
because I dropped my ID on the
street
and I got to my apartment
and I'm getting ready to go,
Andrew and I were coming
back from Philadelphia
we took the train, train to
a cab, cab to my apartment,
got out, and we're up in my
apartment.
I'm there for an hour before
I realize my purse is gone
- How are you paying for
stuff, did you just a wallet
or something also?
- I took my keys out of my
bag while I was on the train,
because I was like I just
want these on my person
I don't know, I probably saw it
coming.
I feel like I've set
myself up to lose my purse,
because I was able to get in my
apartment,
- Some part of your mind
- Knew
- And also, like, some
part of your mind both knew
- But also was like "I'm leaving
this"
- Yes!
That's the interesting thing
- Yes what did I want to leave
in that think, I don't know
because here's the thing
I get in my apartment
and honestly once I
realize I lost my purse
I'm like the only thing
I really need in there
is my passport, eventually,
but not until I need
to travel next which could
be for a couple weeks
and I've lost my ID before on a
trip
and it's a little bit of a
hassle,
but you can get through
security at the airport.
But then,
so I go online and I file the
reports,
and it's Sunday so you can't
get someone on the phone
and I was just like that's fine
- Were you certain at this
point that it was in a cab
- Yeah because I remembered
- [Tom] Because you knew
you had it on the train
- Is it gone?
- Stay tuned
- So I've remembered, I was
really taking myself through
the steps
- Stay tuned I'm going
to tell you right now
- Yeah stay tuned, at the end
of the sentence you will know,
that I got my bag back
and we'll be right back.
So I remember, yeah you just
start trying to remember
the last time, you felt it or
held it.
and I definitely didn't
leave it on the train
- [Tom] (mumbles)
- And I was, It's definitely
in the cab and then,
Andrew was at my apartment, at
the time,
we were about to go to lunch,
so I was like, where's my purse?
I gotta grab it because my
wallet-
and I was like "oh no"
and he was freaking out a
little bit more than I was,
I was like it's fine, I
can pay for things with-
I have a bunch of cash, just
from, just a
drawer of cash- I shouldn't say
that.
- Yeah, yeah...and
where do you live again?
(laughter)
- I had enough cash to get me by
and then
I also, you can just pay
for things electronically.
- [Tom] Yeah like on your phone
and stuff.
- I use my CVS app to pay for
things, I...
You can use ApplePay.
- Yeah
- Starbucks, like the
things I buy are all app.
- Based anyway.
- Yeah, Postmates? I
don't know when I even pay
for things with a credit card
anymore.
- That's true, Seamless
is just a thing where
I'm like, just food comes
when I press this button.
- It's amazing, I used it
for the first time last week
and I was like, oh my god this
works.
- For the first time!
- Like on my phone, on my
phone for the first time.
I have used Seamless a
couple of times before...
- On like a personal computer?
- Yeah I usually get it on a
computer.
- On like an old Dell?
- Yeah, yeah
(laughter)
- I unload an old Dell,
that guy that pops out of
the box, dude you're getting
some food.
- You know the Dell dude
is a Proud Boy, right?
- Is that right!
- No
(laughter)
- Dude I would've totally bought
it,
you could've said that
he is dead or a Proud Boy
I would've been like
yeah that makes sense.
- But I, I called, I was
really just like, oh well
this is life, things could
be so much worse than
losing your stupid purse
like, who cares, I was like
let's just go to lunch I
filled all the things and
because there is, and
oh, I didn't know this
you go "lost item cab",
google that, sends you to a
website, you file a report
and then they make you pay
30 dollars
- That's a scam.
- To place your ad
I almost did the same
thing for Nintendo switch
and people were like, don't do
this.
- I did because I'm like
whatever
and I can pay electronically,
I don't even need my
purse to pay for this loss.
- Too convenient not to spend
the money.
- You're placing an ad where?
I don't even understand.
- [Tom] Exactly
- I was so angry, not because I
had to pay
the 30 dollars but people
who lose their shit
like, no one has 30, and
then they make you pay
to get something back-
it's just ridiculous.
Couldn't get someone on the
phone, and it almost nice
because then I would've been
on hold and I wouldn't have
been able to go to lunch
which is kind of nice
when you're like, well I've
done all that I could do
I am powerless, yes, exactly.
And, so then I went to
lunch and I felt really
fine about it
and I went back home hours
later and I'm getting no emails,
I called a bunch of different
places and they give you
the cab company and I called
them, it doesn't matter.
I had resigned myself to like,
losing my purse and sending
my, Jen, our producer and
my assistant on like a
wild goose chase to
obtain me some kind of ID
which I don't even know
how I begin to do that.
And then I get a call
from like a weird number
and I pick it up and I'm like,
yes!
And its like hey Nikki this
is Ron from the DC Improv
which I will be at next weekend.
- Yes queen.
- This guy calls me from the
DC Improv and press falling
because says DC Improv
and I'm like oh its gonna,
its not my purse.
- Yes
- And he goes, Nikki, its
Ron from the DC Improv,
where is your purse hon.
And I'm like, that's a creepy
way to just say that you
know someone has my purse, just
tell me,
- Do you know where your kid is?
- Just when people kind
of like, shame you about
the thing that, like, so
where is your purse Nikki?
And kind of like a, are
we doing a treasure hunt?
Just be not, just tell me what
you know.
So I know, I don't know, do you
know?
And he's like, I do
know, someone called me.
And I'm like-
- What?
- Why would they have called
you?
So, some guy finds my purse
in the cab, he was the
second passenger after I
had gotten out of the cab
to get in, so someone
just sat next to my purse
and was like "eh I'm not even
gonna tell the cab driver"
- Yeah
- What kind of person
just gets in and doesn't,
first of all take any
money or anything, like,
just leaves it.
- Yeah I would at least
take money and leave.
- I mean you take something and
leave it.
- I feel like all of
you are probably in some
hidden camera show about
morality or some shit.
- Oh that's interesting, yeah.
- That would be great, I would
be like,
yeah I don't give a fuck.
(laughter)
- Do I still get the money?
- I won't sign the release
and all you got is a
blurred face.
- Yeah and I get the cash.
- Yeah...well I, and
this is the benefit of
a just terrible purse, like
just a terrible looking.
It just, I use a tote
bag that I got from H&M
that they give you to put
your clothes in they leave.
Like instead of plastic they
give you a reusable bag,
that's what I use as my purse
because I just don't care.
And so I think someone was
probably like
this is a bag of trash,
which it looks like that too
with a wallet in it, but
there is so much trash inside.
And the guy, I guess the
guy got in and he riffled
through it, I had a lot
of different things,
- Oh yeah but you didn't
have a phone in there.
- [Nikki] No phone, no.
- So how did he contact you.
- So I think he opened my
passport, he opened a check
I have from the weekend working
in Philly,
he found out it was, he googled
me,
went to my website, saw that
the next place I would be
was the DC Improv
- Wow
- [Nikki] A lot of different
ways to get in touch
with me...well...
- Or you can just walk in to
any comedy club in New York
- DM me, oh yeah, there
is that old thing of like,
well I don't have any of
my New York dates listed
on my website so I don't,
but yes, it is easy
we've established that is
very easy to murder me.
If you wanted to murder me,
or any stand up comedian.
- Any comedian, we're just
putting our information
out there.
- Just go to my website-
- But also appearing in
public constantly, at any time
someone could murder you.
- And there is no like,
metal detectors walking into
a show, like anyone could
come murder me any night.
- Yeah we need metal detectors.
- And it'll be weird to play
this someday when it happens
and be like, she predicted it.
I just like to get ahead of
things.
But, and then music
starts, and then she died.
(laughter)
I can see how it's all going
to be edited down later,
Jen have fun with that.
But my post to you
miss...whatever.
So they guy, I get the guy's
number from the DC Improv
guy, I call him and he's
like, he was so funny, he goes
yeah I opened your purse and
I realized, this girl's day
is going to be ruined in 6
different ways because she
doesn't have this bag,
because I had weed in there,
I had a check, I had
eyedrops, I had, I had so many
things that I looked
at the bag to be like,
what would you thing of this
person
- That so funny.
- You would just think
it's a trash person.
- Such a chronic weed habit she
needs eyedrops on the ready.
- I really do, I keep
those things all the time.
- I know I do.
- Do you smoke weed?
- Yeah
- You do!
- You're busted this is a cop
broadcast.
- This is a cop broadcast!
- Oh man
I got busted in Ludlow, and
had PBA card and got off
and got my weed handed back to
me.
- Wow that's tight
- Wait, we gotta get to
that after the break,
all I wanna say is thank
you to Bryan because
he, I called Bryan, I get
Bryan's number and he is like,
he said that he had heard
some Tom Segura bit where
he was like, it was
really weird because I,
Tom Segura has this bit
about, you know you found
someone's walled and he was
just hoping that it would
be someone famous, or
someone and it was just some
normal dude and didn't
matter and he was like,
you know and the I opened
yours and it was like
a famous comedian, and
it felt nice that he
thought I was famous or
whatever but he, he came to
my apartment on his day off
and, from the Upper West side,
he was like, no I'll come
to you and brought it to me
I tried to give him 100
dollars, he wouldn't take it,
I said, he dropped that he
had a girlfriend very quickly
- Ahh just say was he hot, this
could've been a love story.
- Which I was like damn
this could've been so good.
He was adorable and I was
like, can I do anything
and he was like my fiance and I
will come to a show sometime.
- Yeah right, great, thanks
Bryan.
- Bryan just let me give
you money, but he wouldn't
accept the money, I got
my purse back and I just,
it was just so nice, it
just, I needed that yesterday
so badly. I just spend a
lot of time on Instagram
reading, that's where I get my
news
- Yeah, I do it with the Twitter
moments.
- Your news is pictures.
- I know and Twitter moment,
and Reddit, just like,
being said about the world
and like, we're never
going to respect animals or
the planet and I was just like
everyone is trash, and then
Bryan brings me my bag of
trash back, and I really
screamed down the street
I needed you today Bryan,
I was so, it just made me
feel so good.
But I do feel like if you're
spending enough money,
if you take cabs in the city
you are probably well off
enough to now steal from a
purse.
- It's funny I thought that
about the airport though,
I thought, well if you're
at the airport, you're not
going to steal something, you've
already
gotten to the airport.
- I leave my bag all the time
unattended, but your switch,
you left it
- And then somebody took it
though
- At the airport?
- [Tom] Yeah.
- I mean I get that, that free
entertainment in the plane
- That's a good point, damn.
- I agree I don't, I
don't think there is a
difference between-
- Did you steal my fucking
switch?
- Yeah, I do I'm the switch.
- If you're name would've
been on it, you would've
gotten it back, I don't, but
if I find something, like,
there was a sweater at TSA
that was just hanging on,
like, someone had lost a
sweater left it at TSA,
and it was hanging there on
the sign, waiting for a girl
to come back and get, and I just
knew-
- You can't play MarioKart on a
sweater.
- That's a good point.
- But I just knew no one
was coming back for this,
that this sweater was going to
end up in the lost and found
it was a cute sweater, I'm
going to take it, so that's
kind of like the switch
thing, like how am I gonna get
this back to this guy.
- Yeah that's a good point,
I mean, I did, I did the same
the thing you did where I
looked in all that stuff
where you file the report
and that how I found out that
that was a scam, the 30 dollar
thing.
Because I had called the
airport and they were like,
yeah if somebody turns it in,
we have it but nobody did.
- I couldn't be bothered,
if I lost something ,
I would be like, I'm not, I do
not,
I cannot file any paperwork.
- It was only because I
was half way through Zelda
- Oh my god Sarah Silverman
is waving to us and
that just made my morning.
- Sarah and I are just
tracking each other today.
- I know she's, she is not
coming here I don't know
how we didn't get her but,
they have a busy morning
but, I can just do her right
now;
"Hey Nikki, it's so good
to be here, you're so funny
and I really look up to you,
oh is the other way around?
Nevermind"
(laughter)
(rock music)